Maria Menounos reveals she's recovering
from pancreatic cancer shortly after
sharing the news that she's expecting
her first child via surrogate
we're having a baby Maria opens up to
People magazine explaining she was
diagnosed with stage two pancreatic
cancer in January and underwent surgery
three months ago to remove the tumor I
had that moment where I thought I was a
goner but I'm okay because I caught this
early enough I didn't want to stop life
so yeah we're moving forward Maria's
cancer diagnosis came after she was
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes in 2022
and excruciating abdominal pain last
November when she went to the hospital
for her symptoms a CT scan didn't
uncover anything and she says she was
told everything's fine luckily a friend
who owns a company offering full body
MRIs suggested she get one which showed
the mass on her pancreas and a biopsy
confirmed it was a cancerous tumor in
February Maria had the tumor surgically
removed as well as part of her pancreas
her spleen a fibroid and 17 lymph nodes
Maria says it was super painful but
fortunately she doesn't need
chemotherapy or any additional treatment
Beyond a scan every year for the next
five years it ain't about how hard you
hit it's about how hard you can get hit
and keep moving forward it's how we
handle it and how we move forward with
Grace and and that's what I'm trying to
do every single day what makes the
health scare all the more emotional
Maria revealed in February that she and
her husband Kevin undergaro are
expecting their first child together via
surrogate
a long time almost like a decade guys
it's been a long time we've done
everything I mean literally everything
over the years Maria has been open with
ET about her journey to Motherhood do
you see a timeline soon yeah Kevin
actually texted me yesterday he's like
that's it I'm ready back in 2018 shortly
after she and Kevin tied the knot Maria
told E.T they were ready to expand to
the family but they had to consider
their options after Maria had a benign
brain tumor removed the year prior we're
ready to figure it out
um the only
weird thing is that I froze embryos and
I now can't implant them because if I
implant them and do all the hormones the
tumor will grow
there's one way around it that we're
investigating right now and then
otherwise a surrogate by 2019 Maria told
E.T they were moving forward with the
surrogacy process you never know maybe
by next Christmas we'll have
little Marie and Kevin's running around
well now Maria's Baby Dream is coming
true and last week she revealed the
gender on her heel Squad podcast we have
a baby girl coming we've been thinking
about names for years because as you may
or may not know this has been almost a
10-year Journey for us so we've thought
about names forever and I think we've
come up with the perfect name for now
Maria says she's feeling so grateful and
so lucky God granted me a miracle I'm
going to appreciate having her in my
life so much more than I would have
before this journey
[Music]
thank you